I walked in the forest for about an hour.
It was pleasantly cool in the shade of the trees.
I sat down to rest by a large fallen tree, but I was so tired,...
...and the forest was so quiet that I soon fell asleep.
I dreamed that I was married to Princess Flavia and lived in the castle at Zenda.
I had never seen the Princess in real life,...
...but in my dream, I was about to kiss her when I heard a loud voice.
"If you shaved his beard off, he would be the King!"
I thought it was part of my dream, but then I realized that I was awake.
I slowly opened my eyes to see two men looking at me.
The younger man stepped forward. "This is Colonel Sapt," he said,...
..."and I am Count Fritz von Tarlenheim."
"We serve the King of Ruritania."
As he spoke, a man came out of the trees.
I was so surprised that I cried out.
We were almost exactly the same.
He could have been Rudolph Rassendyll...
...and I could have been Rudolph, King of Ruritania!